2016 a marqué la fin de l'événement el
niño un des plus puissants jamais
enregistrés
il a provoqué des crues sans précédent
en amérique du sud
[Musique]
sans lien direct de terribles
inondations se produisirent en europe du
nord
mais cela allait changer du tout au tout
quelques mois plus tard alors que la
planète connaissait le mois d'août le
plus chaud depuis le début des relevés
des sécheresses extrêmes dans plusieurs
régions du globe fit renaître de graves
feux de forêt
[Musique]
les températures élevées à la surface
des océans alimentaire de violentes
tempêtes dans l'atlantique et le
pacifique
la première fois nous avons subi sur
l'atlantique de violence ouragan en même
temps ce qui ne s'était jamais vu
[Musique]
nous pouvons prévoir ces tempêtes mais
il nous est toujours impossible
d'anticiper l'une des catastrophes
naturelles les plus meurtrières sur
terre le tremblement de terre nous avons
constaté de nombreuses catastrophes
moyennes qui sont susceptible de coûter
des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliards de dollars
utilisant des images tournées par des
professionnels dans le feu de l'action
ce film présente les principales
catastrophes naturelles survenues en
2016 des moins funeste pour plus
tragique
[Musique]
ici
dans le sud de la france l'été 2016
restera dans les mémoires comme la
saison la plus sèche jamais enregistrée
la pluviométrie est la plus faible
relevé depuis 1950 avec en juillet et
août
seulement 60 millimètres d'eau tombés en
moyenne en provence ce chiffre est nul
pas une goutte de pluie n'est tombée
pendant l'été conséquence les lacs de la
région véritable oasis pour les hommes
les animaux n'ont plus été alimentée par
les rivières et les cours d'eau desséché
[Musique]
voici à quoi ces mêmes rivière
ressembler au mois d'août 2015
[Musique]
cette pénurie en eau conjuguée à de très
fortes chaleurs fait drastiquement
baisser les niveaux d'humidité dans le
sol preuve en est la situation du lac de
besse sur issole dans le var qui pour la
première fois de son histoire s'est
retrouvé complètement à sec ou presque
voici à quoi le lac devrait ressembler
et voici ce qu'il est devenu
à l'été 2016
[Musique]
la végétation stressé et desséchée par
ces conditions extrêmes et fragilisé à
la moindre petite étincelle elle
s'enflamme
pire un ingrédient fatale vient parfois
s'ajouter à la liste des agressions
levant plus connue localement sous le
nom de mistral ce vent violent assèche
les rend bien
[Musique]
m
le mistral attise le feu dans des
proportions inimaginables
des flammes de plusieurs dizaines de
mètres carbonise instantanément arbres
et plantes et coupent les routes
[Musique]
le 10 août 1500 pompiers furent appelés
pour combattre un immense feu près de
vitrolles aux portes de marseille
il se bâtir au sol et dans les airs mais
la nuit impossible pour les canadairs de
se repérer et donc de voler à vue seuls
les divisions de pompiers au sol peuvent
continuer le combat
[Musique]
en première ligne les rafales de vent
pousse les flammes à des vitesses de
plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres par
heure
[Musique]
la chaleur est telle que même les
racines des plantes sont réduites en
cendres
[Musique]
au total 2016 restera une année record
sur le front des incendies
le bilan est lourd trois cent cinquante
cinq départs de feu et près de 5000
hectares brûlés rien que dans le
département des bouches du rhône aucune
victime n'est à déplorer mais le coût
total des dommages n'est pas loin
d'atteindre les 3 millions d'euros
conséquence indirecte le potentiel de
croissance des arbres survivants est
affaiblie pendant plusieurs années
infesté par les insectes soumis aux
aléas climatiques
certains finiront par périr des mois
après l'incendié
ils laisseront la place aux pins mais
dans certains endroits la fréquence des
feux empêche les pins de parvenir à
maturité sexuelle
les arbres disparaissent progressivement
remplacées par une végétation de
garrigue
ces surfaces brûlées reste cependant
dérisoire en comparaison de celles
ravagées par le gigantesque incendie qui
a frappé la région de fort mcmurray au
canada au mois de mai le feu a démarré
au sud ouest de fort mcmurray le 1er mai
mais le 3 il avait déjà dévasté la
communauté et faisait rage sur
l'autoroute 63 forçant des dizaines de
milliers de personnes à évacuer les
lieux en urgence ce fut la plus
importante évacuation due à un incendie
de toute l'histoire de l'état d'alberta
[Musique]
l' incendie de vinci important qu'ils se
transforma en véritable tempête avec
faudrait vents violents
près de 600 mille hectares de forêt et
environ 2500 habitations partir en fumée
de façon assez incroyable il n'y eu
aucune victime directe du feu mais à ce
jour cet incendie reste la catastrophe
naturelle la plus coûteuse de l'histoire
du canada avec un montant de dommages
assurés atteignant les 4,7 milliards de
dollars
[Musique]
oui
une telle catastrophe est elle
directement liée au réchauffement
climatique
si la saison sèche dure plus longtemps
en particulier après un hiver pluvieux
et que la végétation fournit un bon
combustible
on peut avoir de gros feux de forêt et
quand le vent dépasse une certaine
vitesse il n'y a rien que vous puissiez
faire pour stopper un incendie
on a connu cette situation en californie
il y a quelques années on a vu ça en
grèce au portugal dans le sud de la
france
on a vu ça au printemps dernier au
canada on avait simplement qu'à attendre
que le vent change de direction ou bien
qu'il fasse refluer le feu pour
l'éteindre c'est ce que nous avons connu
cette année et il faut s'attendre à de
plus en plus d'événements de ce type
particulièrement sur le pourtour
méditerranéen qui se réchauffe et
s'assèche de plus en plus
dans l'hémisphère sud le climat a
également provoqué une catastrophe
d'ampleur inhabituel plus précisément à
asuncion la capitale du paraguay qui
s'étend sur les rives du fleuve du même
nom depuis décembre 2015
des pluies diluviennes se sont abattues
sur les bassins versants du fleuve
paraguay et de fortes précipitations ont
entraîné par un puissant et niño font
monter le niveau des cours d'eau au
paraguay en argentine en uruguay et au
brésil mais qu'est ce exactement quel
niño l'événement el niño qui doit son
nom à la période à laquelle il arrive et
qui correspond un peu à noël et le nom
de jésus-christ en espagnol el niño ce
phénomène cyclique commence quand les
eaux chaudes de l'océan pacifique
occidental tropicale se déplace vers
l'est le long de l'équateur en direction
des côtes d'amérique du sud
les eaux de surface chaudes du pacifique
reste alors près des côtes
[Musique]
l'augmentation de ces températures dans
l'est du bassin pacifique décale
l'activité des pluies dans l'est du
bassin donc
donne des anomalies pluie et peut donner
des événements très pluvieux accompagné
d'inondations sur la côte est de
l'amérique du sud
[Musique]
début janvier à asuncion les crues ont
contraint plus de 150000 personnes à
abandonner leur foyer
à différents endroits la capitale a
connu de graves inondations depuis le
mois de novembre à la mi décembre
le niveau du fleuve paraguay avait déjà
atteint six mètres 50
son plus haut niveau de toute l'année
largement supérieur au seuil déjà
critique de 5 mètres 50
beaucoup redoutaient le pire
des milliers de personnes ont été
évacuées des quartiers situés le long de
la rivière quand le niveau du fleuve a
atteint les 7 mètres 84 le 7 janvier
ah oui et c'est chaque fois la crue est
plus intense c'est un lieu où le feu
grandit sans cesse était son lourd et et
dernièrement il est devenu incontrôlable
des mamans fed en décembre je n'ai pas
pu venir jusqu'ici
aujourd'hui j'ai fait un effort pour
venir
mais mon père voyez ce n'est pas facile
d'accès c'est courant c'est une zone
extrêmement inondable et c'est de pire
en pire à cause de la pluie venant du
brésil d'argentine
c'est violent car cela implique beaucoup
de sacrifices les gens pensent toujours
que c'est la dernière fois
cependant cela se reproduit toujours
l'histoire se répète
les gens se mettent à reconstruire et
ils ont à peine le temps de finir que
cela recommence et tout est emporté
mon père a toute sa vie ici ces animaux
sa famille il ne veut pas partir
près de 6000 familles ont été touchées
dans les premières semaines de décembre
après que le niveau du fleuve a franchi
la barre des 7 m le nombre des victimes
a doublé treize mille familles furent
victimes des inondations la plupart
d'entre elles originaire de los banias à
dos le quartier pauvre de la ville situé
tout proche du fleuve
[Musique]
le gouvernement paraguayen déclara
l'état d'urgence à asuncion ainsi que
dans sept autres régions du pays
pareillement affectés
le phénomène el niño se produit de
manière aléatoire à peu près tous les
deux à sept ans et dure de 12 à 18 mois
engendrant des risques répétez
d'inondations dans les zones exposées et
la menace d'épidémie de choléra et de
paludisme
l'eau n'est pas allé jusqu'à la maison
elle est d'abord monté petit à petit et
puis c'est venu d'un coup ça s'est passé
comme ça en 74 ou 75
cette année nous allons et ayons des
deux fois l'eau est montée jusqu'au mur
la marque est arrivé quasiment à 9 m
nous sommes prêts à rester parce que
j'aime ma vie ici
le problème c'est la salle de bain la
lumière et les maladies pas moins de 200
pylônes électriques ont été détruits par
les plus torrentielles laissant des
milliers de foyers sans électricité
quatre personnes ont trouvé la mort
victimes de chutes d'arbres dans ce qui
fut considéré comme les pires
inondations depuis un demi siècle
[Musique]
le montant total des dégâts est estimé à
3,5 millions de dollars quelques mois
plus tard c'est encore un phénomène
météorologique exceptionnel qui s'est
produit en europe en mai 2016
un système de hautes pressions était
stationnaire au dessus de l'europe
septentrionale entraînant un temps sec
et beau pendant que tout le coeur de
l'europe était sous le couvert de basse
pression elle aussi stationnaire
cela provoqua des pluies
beaucoup de pluie
de violentes averses fin mai et début
juin gauzère de sérieux problèmes sur
tout le nord de l'europe en particulier
en france et en allemagne
en france ce sont quelques unes des
pires inondations depuis un siècle qui
ont été recensés dans certaines régions
c'est l'équivalent de six semaines de
pluie qui est tombée en trois jours les
événements qu'on a connu cet été sans
partie du cycle naturel même s'ils sont
des événements rares et extrême est
dramatique
il n'en reste pas moins qu'ils font
partie des cycles naturels on peut pas
les attributs ennemis au réchauffement
climatique niño
à paris au tout début du mois de juin la
scène atteint des niveaux inégalés
depuis près de 30 ans
depuis 200 ans la statue du zouave sous
le pont de l'alma est la mesure
symbolique du niveau de la seine pour
les parisiens
le niveau du fleuve a grimpé jusqu'à 6
mètres 10 c'est la plus importante
inondation dans la capitale depuis 1982
quand les eaux étaient montées jusqu'à 6
mètres 18 mais elles n'ont pas atteint
le niveau de la crue historique de 1910
8 m 62
l'élévation du niveau de l'eau a conduit
plusieurs musées dont le louvre et le
musée d'orsay a déplacé quelques unes de
leurs collections pour les mettre à
l'abri et les transports publics à
prendre des précautions pour le métro
notamment la ratp a mis en pratique des
procédures d'urgence visant à fermer la
circulation au train lorsque le niveau
de la seine atteint 5 m 10 l'inondation
à paris a été provoquée par de très
violentes précipitations dans l'est de
la france
autre victime de ces déluges à un
monument français bien connu le château
de chambord
il s'est retrouvé les pieds dans l'eau
lorsque la rivière cosson est sortie de
son lit au même moment que paris était
inondée
la cour royale et le parterre du château
de françois 1er furent totalement
submergé
on a vu qu'on avait à faire un événement
aux conséquences imprévisibles
on a évacué certaines maisons qui
commence à être inondées un pavillon
forestier un gîte rural une maison en
bordure du du monument le lendemain
matin donc mercredi on a coupé
l'électricité dans les parties basses du
château parce qu'en fait l'abonnement
c'est vide
il y avait un mètre cinquante d'eau qui
avait monté en fait le niveau des douves
sous sont trouvés sous la cour ce
château a été merveilleusement construit
et pas leur le donjon à côté duquel on
est et bien en fait il est rehaussé de 1
m par rapport au sol donc il était
calculée sans doute par rapport au cru
qu'on pouvait observer dans le cosson
c'est à une oeuvre de génie et c'est
quand même assez hallucinant et assez
émouvant de voir que cinq siècles après
il résiste à un épisode météorologique
qui est au moins centrale est en tout
cas sans précédent connu
non loin de chambord à tour en sologne
la crue a atteint un mètre soixante
les gens ont été surpris en pleine nuit
par la montée des eaux
ma mère à 79 ans heureusement mon frère
manger chez ma mère et il a dit don
qu'il avait vu deux trois centimètres à
10 heures du soir de trois centimètres
d'eau il a dit bon ben on va survivre à
surélever les meubles ils ont tout mis
sur cale
ils ont essayé de sauver des trucs aller
ils ont mis des choses à laitages je
vous dis mon bas
donc ma mère est allé dormir chez mon
frère heureusement 79 ans chose que josé
le voisin n'a pas eu
il n'a pas eu cette chance là il s'est
réveillé les pieds dans l'eau quoi le
lit flottait quoi bomber à la voiture la
super 5
elle est plus tellement super tout le
monde s'est fait surprendre là on n'a
rien pu sauver rien du tout ça c'est
jamais arrivée ma mère 81 ans donc à
jamais vu ça un de sa mémoire
ça s'est jamais vu quoi j'ai jamais eu
des crues enfin une crue comme ça c'est
ici c'est extraordinaire
pour les agriculteurs de la région les
inondations ont des conséquences
désastreuses
on s'imagine pas trop qu'il ya un champ
de maïs
c'est un bolat au carré les pompiers
sont arrivés ils ont il faut absolument
évacuer sinon tout le monde va mourir
donc là effet de panique on avait quand
même de loi 90 cm c'était c'était quand
même assez dur quand on est arrivé au
bout et on s'est dit en fait on peut se
faire piéger très très rapidement par
l'eau là on savait pas ce qui pouvait se
passer
et là on a eu peur on a pris conscience
de la crue vraiment l'ol a une puissance
extraordinaire et avec le courant on
s'est dit finalement on pouvait vite se
faire piéger et deux jours après mon
avis ça va vraiment coupé les pattes
quoi on est revenu sur la ferme et là on
voit l'étendue des dégâts
on voit que baker que le blé en fait
l'eau est passée au dessus des épi ça
veut dire qu'il y aura rien n'y aura pas
de récolte et sur le jardin c'est pareil
l'année dernière on avait noyé un tout
petit peu là c'est tout était sous l'eau
donc les fraises elles sont formées il y
avait des fraises rouge dire fraises de
presse déjà formé quelques jours sous
l'eau n'est pas besoin d'être
agriculteur pour savoir que ça présage
rien de bon des crues tardive comme ça
c'est très rare au niveau du co sont
pour moi c'est une crue centennale
une crue du la crue du siècle quatre
personnes sont mortes et 42 ont été
blessées dans tout le pays
le coût des inondations en france fut
estimé à 800 millions d'euros
de telles tempêtes des climats tempérés
sont moins structurés moins
spectaculaire et moins meurtrière que
les tempêtes tropicales
le climat change l'atmosphère se
réchauffe
ce qui entraîne aussi le réchauffement
de l'océan et des océans chaussons le
carburant idéal pour les ouragans et les
typhons
taïwan a été particulièrement touchée
par les typhons cette année de récentes
recherches s'accordant à souligner que
le pouvoir destructeur de ces tempêtes a
augmenté de 50% lors des quarante
dernières années
en 2016 la saison des typhons dans le
pacifique a démarré tardivement par la
première tempête tropicale nominé par
tak qui a ouvert les hostilités le 3
juillet seulement
à ses débuts ce n'était qu'une zone de
basse pression au dessus de l'archipel
orientale des carolines reclassés en
typhon le 5 juillet
avec des sauts à plus de 30 degrés dans
toute la mer des philippines n'est par
taqa été requalifiés en super typhon le
soir du 5 juillet atteignant son
intensité maximale
al'approche de taitung sur la côte sud
est de taïwan avec une pression de 900
millibars et des vents de plus de 200
kilomètres heure
mais par thack traverse à taïwan le 7
juillet
[Musique]
sur la partie est il y à de grandes
montagnes et très peu de personnes
vivent à l'est toute l'activité
l'activité économique les grandes villes
parce que toute la population et les
bâtiments sont concentrés sur le côté
ouest de l'île
la région des plaines et la plupart des
typhons arrive d'un axe sud est donc ils
ont tendance à toucher d'abord les
montagnes mais par taqa causé trois
décès sur l'île mais allait provoquer la
mort de 83 personnes en chine et un
milliard et demi de dollars de dommages
au total trois mois plus tard un second
typhons frappent à taïwan
baptisé mer en ti il a été évalué comme
le cyclone tropical le plus puissant au
monde sur l'année 2016 est l'un des
cyclones tropicaux les plus violents
jamais enregistrés
la tempête s'est formée à l'ouest de
guam dans la partie occidentale de
l'océan pacifique
le 11 septembre elle est requalifiée en
typhon s'intensifie rapidement le 12
septembre et devient un super typhon de
catégorie 5 avec des vents soutenus
enregistrés à plus de 240 km/heure et
une pression atmosphérique de 890
millibars meranti ravages à l'extrême
sud de taïwan
[Musique]
deux personnes périrent et plus de 700
mille habitations se retrouvèrent sans
eau et sans électricité
la tempête continue à détruire près de
300 habitations aux philippines et causé
la mort de 30 personnes dans les
inondations qui s'en sont suivies en
chine le 21 septembre près de guam
encore une dépression tropicale ce
format elle se transforma en typhon le
23 septembre
mais guy
il atteignait l'intensité maximale d'un
typhon de catégorie 3 7 fois sur l'île
même frappant de plein fouet la ville de
hualien yens sur la côte est pacifique
de taïwan avec des vents soutenus de
plus de 160 km heure et une pression
atmosphérique de 940 millibars
lorsque meggie s'abattit sur la côte des
vagues gigantesques déferlèrent causant
l'une des pires panne générale de toute
l'histoire de l'île et laissant plus de
3 millions de foyers sans électricité
toutefois contrairement à ce que la
taille des vagues auraient pu laisser
craindre les dégâts ne furent pas aussi
catastrophique que prévu
le dernier de ses tifos on prenne à des
vitesses de vent plutôt élevé des
vitesses de vent qui dans beaucoup de
pays aurait été fort dommageable à
taiwan en particulier sur le port
principal de kaohsiung le typhon
entraîna des vents très violents mais ne
causera pas de très grand dommage parce
que les bâtiments à taïwan sont très
bien conçu
alors que l'oeil de la tempête traversée
lille les vents changèrent de direction
mais guy oblige à plus de 14 mille
personnes à être évacuées des zones
montagneuses près de la côte vers les
centres d'urgence
91 personnes perdirent la vie et le
total des dommages de sétif ont su
destructeur a été estimé à 1,25 milliard
de dollars
[Musique]
les chercheurs alerte sur le fait que
c'est énorme tempête vont devenir bien
plus puissante dans le futur
menaçant les populations côtières sans
cesse croissante des pays du pacifique
ses habitants font également face à des
épreuves bien plus sournoise je peux
voir les catastrophes
la majeure partie des catastrophes les
catastrophes qui sont à la une des
journaux et on peut estimer le coût des
dégâts causés par la plus grosse
catastrophe connue mais il ya aussi ce
que l'on appelle des risques insidieux
des catastrophes insidieuse quand les
choses bougent lentement qui on le sait
ont déjà commencé à causer beaucoup de
pères et qui vont causer encore plus de
pertes dans le futur et le plus
important d'entre elles est la montée du
niveau de la mer qui monte de 3 mm
chaque année à présent l'une des
estimations que l'on a des conséquences
de la hausse du niveau de la mer c'est
une estimation de 2006 qui est évalué à
1 trion c'est à dire un million de
millions de dollars
les risques si le niveau de la mer
s'élève à 1 m parce que si vous
réfléchissez à toutes les
infrastructures qui se trouve au niveau
de la mer sport station d'épuration
hôtel raffinerie pétrochimique aéroports
toutes ces choses sont construites juste
au dessus du niveau de la mer et si le
niveau de la mer monte
elles devront être relocalisés
conséquence directe de la croissance
démographique
d'autres événements futures vont devenir
plus dévastateur encore 2016 illustre le
défi de vivre sur une planète
tectoniques mans active
l'océan pacifique est ceinturé par un
réseau de failles d'origine tectonique
et de volcans baptisé la ceinture de feu
du pacifique au nord ouest de cette
ceinture en dessous et kyushu les îles
les plus peuplées du japon sont à la
jonction de plusieurs plaques la plaque
océanique des philippines
ils rentrent en collision avec plusieurs
plaques eurasienne et créer une faille
médiane qui circule sous les îles du sud
ouest à l'est à l'extrémité sud de cette
zone de rupture la préfecture de
kumamoto est construite sur un mille
feuilles de roche
chaque année plusieurs dizaines de
secousses telluriques qui sont
ressenties au mois d'avril 2016 une
série de tremblements de terre a frappé
la zone de kumamoto avec une secousse
principale de magnitude 7 le 16 avril
l'épicentre du séisme se situe à
quelques 100 km au sud est de sendai sur
l'île de honshu à l'endroit où un
tremblement de terre et un tsunami ont
tout dévasté en mars 2011
ces six matchs ou ne se situait pas sur
la plaque de la zone de subduction mais
sur une zone sur laquelle il ya de
nombreuses failles actives qui court sur
tout le centre de kyushu les routes
furent terriblement endommagé entre le
14 et le 20 avril ce sont plus de 600
répliques sismiques qui ont été
ressenties dont deux particulièrement
forte
quinze mille soldats de l'armée
japonaise prirent part aux opérations de
secours dans les jours qui suivirent le
tremblement de terre
la recherche et le sauvetage
c'est l'une de nos priorités majeures et
pour être honnête nous sommes frustrés
ha oui car nous ne pouvons pas y aller
pour le moment les répliques continuent
nous devons être prudents car la nature
ne permet pas l'optimisme
[Musique]
outre les effondrements de maisons et
d'immeubles de nombreux glissements de
terrains se produisirent de l'autre côté
de la chaîne montagneuse de kyushu
balafrant les coteaux et provoquant
l'effondrement du grand-pont d'assaut
sur la nationale 3 125 dans la rivière
kurokawa
[Musique]
de mémoire d'homme c'est du jamais vu
il y a déjà eu plusieurs glissements de
terrain de grande ampleur cinq ans
auparavant ils ont été classifiés en
tant que désastre national
cela a causé d'énormes dégâts je ne suis
pas sûr que ceux ci soient plus gros
comparé au précédent
en tout cas ils continuent mais de gros
rochers qui n'ont jamais bougé
auparavant sont tombés cette fois vous
pouvez apercevoir sur la montagne les
zones où il ya du sol rouge suite aux
glissements
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 17 avril le premier ministre japonais
shinzo abe mobilisent à 3000 soldats de
l'armée de l'air pour permettre aux
autorités locales d'atteindre les zones
sinistrées
[Musique]
je fais partie des équipes de recherche
et de sauvetage
à l'heure actuelle nous recherchons des
personnes qui ont disparu
c'est la première fois que je vois un
tremblement de terre et un glissement de
terrain d'une telle ampleur depuis que
je suis arrivé ici nous avons déjà
trouvé de quatre personnes
une personne de plus reste introuvable
donc nous allons chercher toute la nuit
c'était une occurrence naturel et
personne n'a rien vu venir
nous n'avons aucun indice
on ne sait pas où les maisons ont été
emportées
en faisant des recherches basées sur des
suppositions
le temps presse pour retrouver des
survivants l'équipe se prépare à passer
une nuit blanche
[Musique]
kenny mais à trois personnes yamaguchi
ils ne sont pas encore ici on sent déjà
descendu là bas et sont déjà descendus
l'an dernier la nôtre c'est tout
maintenant je descends je veux ouvrir la
voie sommes-nous sur la liste de
personnes
oui vous pouvez venir avec nous nous
laisserons les matériels là où sont les
équipes en attente la zone attentes n'a
pas encore été décidé donc vous voyez le
laisser à proximité de la maison
plusieurs dizaines de personnes ont été
tirés des décombres
les sauveteurs font l'impossible pour
trouver d'autres survivants
avant les averses prévues et de
nouvelles secousses
le 18 avril vingt-quatre personnes ont
été retrouvés sans vie
onze étaient toujours portées disparues
et plus de 91000 ont dû être évacuées
le nombre de personnes à reloger avait
atteint les 180 mille autres résultats
des secousses la ville entière de
kumamoto s'est retrouvé privé d'eau
nous ne transportons des provisions par
le sol et par les airs avec des
hélicoptères de l'armée japonaise ou
américaine plus courants nous
fournissons aussi de l'eau beaucoup de
zones n'ont plus accès à l'eau courante
à 7 56 préparer des repas avec des
provisions limitées fait partie de notre
entraînement donc cela fait partie de
nos responsabilités
le 19 avril la peur de nouvelles
répliques poussa encore plus d'habitants
à élire refuge dans les voitures les
stades et les espaces ouverts
[Musique]
les autorités gouvernementales ont
estimé à plus de 1000 le nombre
d'immeubles fortement endommagé et à 90
le nombre d'immeubles complètement
détruit
mais quand même énorme l'épicentre du
premier a été un machinima chier et le
second a été dans la région de la
deuxième fois la maison s'est effondrée
ça s'est passé à peu près à 1h25 du
matin c'était comme si mon corps était
projeté de part et d'autre sur environ 1
m j'étais juste là où il ya la table du
salon en dessous de l'horloge je dormais
en dessous de la table
je pensais que je serais plus en
sécurité et qu'elle me protégerait si
quelque chose tombait sur moi
quan is you gonna mining cette partie là
avait deux étages et en bas il y avait
un garage et ma chance je suis terrifiée
à l'idée de savoir me serait arrivé si
j'avais été dans ma chambre en bas sa
présentation
la voiture a été écrasée comme une crêpe
on est là depuis cinq ans une fois par
an nous avons eu un tremblement de terre
de magnitude 3 ou 4 je pense que c'était
un signe un signe d' alerte
bien que le foyer du séisme se soient
situées sous le mont kin two au nord
ouest du centre ville de kumamoto les
zones les plus touchées furent matshiqi
miku beau dans la banlieue est de
kumamoto
la demeure de sato mi-août au mot ami
kubo été construite juste sur la ligne
de rupture son avenir reste incertain
faites attention où vous mettez les
pieds s'il vous plaît croyez moi j'ai
peur j'ai vraiment peur de rester dans
ma maison
ce qu'il y ait encore de nombreuses
répliques
si je reste à l'intérieur et qu'une
réplique ce produit comme cette maison
est déjà tout de travers la maison
pourrait s'effondrer
ça me fait très peur on dormait ici à ce
moment là l'armoire est tombé ici et par
là c'était le chaos ici cette porte
on pouvait plus l'ouvrir elle était
complètement bloquée quand on a voulu
s'échapper
il n'y avait plus que cette petite
ouverture pour se sauver
notre unique volonté à ce moment là
c'était survivre en s'échappant la
chambre des enfants et de ce côté là
quand je repense à ce moment j'étais
complètement terrorisée j'avais très
peur
retournons au même moment les placards à
vaisselle se sont ouverts et toutes les
assiettes et les verres sont tombés par
terre des hommes comptent encore
crossing le frigo était de ce côté là on
y est cette étagère était comme ça mais
plus tourner des scènes auxquelles
désordre si aujourd'hui j'ai envie de
reconstruire une nouvelle maison mais je
suis très angoissé par le futur alors la
reconstruire ici c'est inquiétant parce
que le terrain est située sur une faille
tectonique et qu'il risque d'y avoir
d'autres tremblements de terre croate et
tout ça m'angoisse chez nous on a de la
chance car le voisinage nous a beaucoup
aidés continent à chaque jour nos
voisins nous ont donné à manger et nous
ont réconfortés
ils nous ont écouté tes dents lors ça
s'il est d'accord avec eux grâce à eux
on arriva à surmonter toutes ces
épreuves
ilona d'accord ici à la campagne
l'entr'aide fonctionne beaucoup
nous avons tous été victimes et tout le
monde s'entraide un écran qui est si on
n'a pas de quoi manger on s'invite les
uns chez les autres
et toute cette gentillesse nous touche
énormément et ça c'est plus important
que l'argent
comme avant le toit de la grange était
relié à celui de la maison mais
maintenant la charpente est complètement
voyez ici on peut voir la faille dans le
sol
ce pays notamment le 21 avril le mauvais
temps si redouté arrive et il va encore
compliquer le travail des sauveteurs
pire il est accompagné de répliques
provoquant la destruction dans la nuit
d'une partie du patrimoine culturel de
kyushu
elles ont sévèrement endommagé le temple
assauts un sanctuaire shinto c'est
important monument japonais a perdu sa
tour portail ainsi que sa salle de culte
l'eau de pluie s'infiltre par les
fissures et risque de favoriser les
glissements de terrain sur le sol meuble
la falaise s'effondre à cause de la
pluie
les habitants des maisons au dessous de
la falaise ont été ordonné d'évacuer
nous sommes donc en train de vérifier si
tout est réglé il ya eu des secousses de
haut en bas
là on tient pour le moment mais il peut
casser à tout moment donc nous devons
être présents oui des glissements
peuvent encore survenir
donc soyez prudents
parmi les plus exposées les maisons
autour dassault ou le 17 avril la faille
en activité déplaça latéralement le sol
de 2 m les fondations des bâtiments sont
désormais ancré dans un sol en partie
liquéfié le séisme transforma la terre
en soupe
nous sommes impuissants devant les
forces de la nature
je me console en me disant que je ne
pouvais rien y faire nous vivons
seulement à deux dans cette maison nous
pensons vivre avec d'autres gens
maintenant même dans des logements
temporaires pour un temps seulement
toutes les maisons ici ont été détruites
le second jour le premier jour la route
a commencé à se dégrader
trois arbres et un poteau électrique
sont tombés sur ma maison mes jambes
tremblent de peur
autour d'assaut les terres solide se
liquéfiait engloutissant route ces
voitures et faisant même basculer les
bâtiments restés sur le sol meuble ce
processus de liquéfaction constitua la
part la plus destructrice de la
catastrophe
les scientifiques se sont depuis
longtemps et forcé d'étudier ce
phénomène mais les chercheurs
s'accordent maintenant à dire que
beaucoup de leurs modèles présentent des
imperfections échoue à donner une
représentation exacte des conditions
réellement existante
une liquéfaction survient généralement
dans les sols sableux quand le sable
remue pendant la secousse
la pression fait que le sol devient
liquide sur la cause des affaissements
du sol les maisons se penche comme celle
derrière nous car le sol ne pouvait plus
la supporter le terrain ici à la
particularité géologique d'être
recouverte de cendres volcaniques qui se
sont accumulés sur les pentes de la
montagne au beau milieu de la tourmente
et de la confusion une équipe de
sismologues japonais se mettent au
travail pour établir une modélisation 3d
des zones touchées
il essaie de comprendre les structures
tectonique du lieu et les forces en
mouvement
regardez cette zone ça s'est transformé
en un escalier le sol est très mou je
pense que lorsque des gros morceau de
terrain ont glissé à mme sa surface a
continué à glisser ce n'est pas souvent
qu'on voit une montagne s'effondrer
comme ça
[Musique]
gros bureaux qui nie nous prenons des
photos de la zone toutes les cinq
secondes
nous utilisons ces photos prises sous
différents angles pour créer un modèle
3d de la zone dans cette région
plusieurs zones se sont écroulés nous
regardons d'abord la photo intégral
avant de décider où nous voulons voir
les coupes transversales les mesures
peuvent être faites à la main mais si
nous avons besoin de sections
différentes
nous devons les refaire ces pratiques
avec cette machine car nous pouvons
bouger et voir des sections différentes
failles est clairement active ici et je
pense qu'elle va s'agrandir
si les tremblements de terre continue
[Musique]
le japon vit en permanence sous la
menace de nouveaux séismes et éruptions
volcaniques
le pays entier est sous la surveillance
constante des sismologues et des
volcanologues 20% des séismes que subit
notre planète touche le japon chaque
année autour de 600 séisme par an
[Musique]
ainsi le 22 novembre 2016 un autre
violent tremblement de terre de
magnitude 7,1 fut ressenti au nord du
japon près de fukushima causant
heureusement plus de peur que de mal
au total la série de séismes à kumamoto
et dans le reste du japon a en 2016
causé la mort de 49 personnes et
occasionné des dommages estimés à 7 5
milliards de dollars
quelques mois après que la plaque
tectonique philippines a fait les gros
titres de la presse
les mouvements d'une autre plaque
tectonique firent des ravages en italie
[Musique]
le bassin méditerranéen est broyé par le
continent africain qui s'enfonce sous la
plaque eurasienne générant de complexes
faille de subduction prises entre les
deux la plaque adriatique tourne dans le
sens inverse des aiguilles d'une montre
à la vitesse de 3 mm par an autour de la
ville d'hama trichet et des villages
voisins de la chaîne montagneuse des
apennins au centre de l'italie
[Musique]
ces villages de montagne isolés sont
connus pour leur huile d'olive leurs
truffes noires et leurs vignobles
24 août 3h30 du matin
un tremblement de terre d'une magnitude
6,2 puissant bien que peu profonds fera
pas les villages
[Musique]
les villes d'art quoi tu as préparé et
biscarrat del tronto furent parmi les
plus violemment touchés dans cette
région le prêtre local francesco armandi
est la mémoire vivante de ce village la
nuit du 24 août à 3h36 précisément nous
avons entendu un grand fracas et la
terre a tremblé de manière violente
j'étais au lit mais réveillez et on
avait l'impression que la nature voulait
projeter mon lit au plafond j'ai attendu
la fin de la secousse
je me suis habillé rapidement et je suis
sorti les rues étaient pleines de
gravats de cailloux et de grosses
pierres et toute la population est sorti
dans la rue je me suis levé j'ai enfilé
mes chaussons j'ai pris mon fils et
avant même la fin de la première
secousse
nous étions déjà dans l'escalier arrivé
en bas nous sommes aperçus que nous
étions pyjama à 3 heures du matin j'ai
dit non à la seconde secousse
on a entendu le mauve et or et
un bruit effroyable à cet instant tout
s'est écroulé
je me suis dit ma mamie nous étions
justement sur le parking d'un côté et on
entendait le fracas des pierres depuis
la crête du veto ray qui roulait
jusqu'en bas avec la secousse du
tremblement de terre en dix minutes
tu regardes ce qu'il ya autour de toi tu
vois la désolation la maison et sur pied
mais si tu ne peux pas y vivre c'est
comme si tout s'était arrêté et voir ton
village qui n'existe plus c'est encore
plus dur
le bus de l'école arrive ici j'ai
récupéré mon fils ici plein de fois je
le faisais goûté on allait chercher une
brioche emballé c'était la vie simple et
essentielle mais c'était la vie je ne
l'aurais plus excusez moi outre les
pertes humaines
une partie du patrimoine culturel de
l'italie fut également ravagé une église
s'est écroulé à pescara b elle a
certainement milan elle ne s'était
jamais écroulé pourtant des tremblements
de terre il y en a déjà eu
ce qui veut dire que celui ci était
beaucoup plus violent il ne s'agit pas d
secousse colossale que l'on observe à la
lisière des plaques tectoniques où des
séismes de magnitude 8 et 9 peuvent se
produire dans cette région les failles
sont plutôt petites car peu profondes
mais quand le séisme se produit juste au
dessus la secousse est spectaculaire
la réalité c'est que nous ne sommes
qu'un petit point sur la carte
géographique mieux nous sommes sur une
petite étoile son stylo sur le site de
l'institut de géophysique italien
on représente l'épicentre avec une
étoile
plus de 4000 personnes ont participé aux
opérations de recherches et de secours
238 personnes furent retirées vivantes
des décombres grâce à l'intervention des
autorités
[Musique]
les tremblements de terre sont à l'image
des balles d'une roulette russe
on ne peut jamais vraiment savoir quand
et où ils vont déchaîner leur pouvoir
destructeur
[Musique]
nous nous sommes rendu compte que nous
étions de vrais miraculé parce qu'après
taré mais à part ça mise à part les
dégâts que nous voyons derrière nous il
n'y a pas eu de mort il n'y a pas eu de
blessés puis nous avons vu pescara alors
nous avons remonter nos manches
nous nous sommes dit que nous sommes
encore là et que nous pouvions faire
quelque chose ce qui est arrivé à
pescara c'est incroyable
[Musique]
le village malheureusement a été
complètement détruit d'ailleurs si vous
y allez vous ne verrez plus qu'un tas de
ruines
il ya eu près de 50 morts ces personnes
je les connaissais je les avait mariés
j'avais baptiser leurs enfants alors je
suis un peu sous le choc parce que quand
20 30 40 ou 50 ami meurt c'est forcément
un drame intérieur et une douleur
profonde
c'est sûr nous aurons certainement des
difficultés à nous reprendre pour
repartir
[Musique]
j'ai vécu le tremblement de terre de
1972 et de 1997 celui de l' aquila que
nous avons ressenti ici parce que nous
sommes relativement proche
mais pour moi ils n'ont pas eu cette
violence cette fois ci par contre il
semble que le tremblement de terre a
suivi une ligne une ligne maudite comme
pescara détruites et à côté il ya un
village vezzano qui n'est qu'à 500
mètres environ
totalement inde m rien ne s'est écroulé
alors ce sont des phénomènes que moi du
moins je n'arrive pas à comprendre
la science peut-elle expliquer ces
étranges phénomènes les montagnes se
sépare en deux et vous avez des séismes
successifs qui court du sud au nord
l'un après l'autre à des semaines et des
mois d'intervalle créant des failles des
failles très connue des failles que vous
pouvez voir et ben les façades
montagneuse dans ces régions qui ont
connu le plus fort séisme
depuis des centaines d'années
ces failles ont été brisées une par une
créant une brèche
plus au nord le long de l'axé principal
des monts apennins en italie
[Musique]
ce n'est ni la première ni la dernière
fois que l'italie connaît un fort
tremblement de terre
entre le 26 octobre et le 3 novembre une
dizaine de séismes superficiels avec des
magnitudes 4,5 à 6,5 ont frappé en série
la région de macerata
ils se sont produits dans une faille
sismique entre la zone touchée par le
séisme du mois d'août et l'ombrie une
zone frappée en 1997 les failles se
développent et le processus de
destruction se poursuit 298 personnes
sont mortes dans le tremblement de terre
on estime à près de 2,5 milliards
d'euros le montant total des dommages
[Musique]
des magistrats italiens ont ouvert une
enquête afin de vérifier si les
entreprises de construction avaient
passé outre les réglementations anti
sismique lors de la restauration de
bâtiments publics comme une école à
amath reach est réduite en miettes lors
du tremblement de terre
une controverse similaire est toujours
vive de l'autre côté de l'atlantique où
les plaques tectoniques son responsable
de l'une des pires catastrophes de 2016
l'océan pacifique le plus grand et le
plus profond des océans au monde cache
sous sa surface un réseau de failles
conséquence de la tectonique des plaques
en particulier à l'ouest où l'immense
plaque de nazca s'enfonce sous le
continent sud-américain à la vitesse de
60 mm par an
cette rencontre d'une plaque océanique
avec une plaque continentale créé des
frictions et qui dit friction de
l'écorcé terrestre dit volcan et séisme
en équateur 60% des 16 millions
d'habitants vivent dans les régions
côtières et notamment dans la ville
principale guayaquil
le 16 avril vers 19 heures la terre
gronde à et des pannes d'électricité
affectèrent de nombreuses villes
[Musique]
c'est au grand jour seulement que le
gouvernement réalise à l'amplitude et
l'étendue des dégâts causés par ce
tremblement les villes de porto viejo
pedernales est ce mandat et khanh hoà
furent parmi les plus touchés mais le
fait que le tremblement de terre se
produisent à la fin de la journée
juste avant que les habitants elle se
couche et permis d'épargner de
nombreuses avec une magnitude 7,8 sur
l'échelle de richter
ce fut le tremblement de terre le plus
puissant de l'année 2016 et en equateur
le séisme le plus important depuis 1979
le président rafael correa a déclaré
l'état d'urgence et dépêché à 13500
membres de l'armée des forces de police
et des pompiers
je suis responsable de la zone qui a été
le plus touché une zone commerciale en
pleine activité au moment où s'est
déroulée la tragédie
les secouristes sont arrivés sur tous
les points critiques pendant les deux
premières heures les pompiers se sont
déplacés dans toute la zone et ont
réussi à sauver des victimes il y a eu
beaucoup de survivants
puis il a fallu chercher les corps sans
vie
on dénombra plus de 600 décès dans les
province de manabi et esmeraldas et au
total plus de 6000 blessés
le tremblement de terre s'est produit à
une heure qui grâce à dieu à épargner
des vies
les gens travaillent et où ils étaient
dans la rue si cela s'était passé une
heure plus tardive ou très tôt dans la
matinée
cela aurait été encore plus compliqué et
il y aurait eu encore plus de perdre du
maine fait comme si quelqu'un avait
soulevé ma maison elle avait j'étais sur
des vagues de 15 mètres
ça balance et de tous les côtés landes
est arrivé quand j'étais chez moi je
pouvais voir la montagne se soulever
vers le haut j'ai aussi vu bouger une
partie des bâtiments de la ville
j'ai vu les maisons en face se levaient
s'affaisser et se relever
[Musique]
on
pedernales s se trouve tout près du
point de jonction des plaques
cette ville de 40000 habitants fut
particulièrement touchés et beaucoup de
ces édifices sur complètement détruit
[Musique]
notre maison était composée de cinq
étages et allemands mais quand les
répliques se sont arrêtés j'avais perdu
cinq membres de ma famille ma soeur de
17 ans est toujours sous le choc elle a
vu le bâtiment s'effondrer un entier et
ma mère a vu l'effondrement d'un
bâtiment de 16 étages derrière moi dont
il ne reste plus rien il a été
entièrement détruit sous l'eau près de
trente mille personnes se retrouvèrent
sans abris l'eau le gaz et l'électricité
furent coupés dans de nombreux endroits
et des centaines de kilomètres de routes
furent détruits beaucoup ont perdu leur
gagne pas la douleur qui restera
toujours c'est celle ci des années de
travail des cheveux en moins des cheveux
blancs tout est parti il ne reste plus
rien vingt ans de ma vie
on a commencé par une petite propriété
un peu plus loin en bas puis on a changé
on est venu là à force d'efforts et de
sacrifices
on s'est endettée pendant 18 ans pour
rembourser la construction mais avec la
physique
on ne peut pas tricher la structure
s'est vrillé au niveau du troisième et
du quatrième étage
[Musique]
pis pour un chat les gens étaient sous
le choc tout le monde était assis là à
regarder
moi aussi j'étais choqué je ne pouvais
pas imaginer que quelque chose comme ça
pouvait arriver
mais depuis nous avons reçu de l'aide
nous avons commencé à recevoir l'aide de
la communauté la coordination
c'est ça le gros truc d'essayer de
coordonner les efforts de tout le monde
c'est de façon à remettre sur pied cet
endroit les gens commencent à rebâtir
leur maison et c'est formidable on
essaie de travailler avec les autorités
locales pour s'assurer que les normes de
construction sont bien en place afin que
quelque chose comme ça ne puisse plus
jamais se reproduire
l'équateur bahia et toute cette région
est une zone sismique extrêmement active
à travers l'histoire nous avons eu des
épisodes sismiques et ce n'est pas fini
cela n'est pas près de changer l'ampleur
et le mécanisme focal du tremblement de
terre d'avril sont typiques de ceux
d'une zone de subduction entre deux
plaques de grande taille
un tel mécanisme produits les plus
puissants séismes que l'on puisse
connaître et quand la terre a tremblé
inévitablement de nouvelles secousses
vont se produire aux alentours ou bien
exactement au même endroit
nous voyons aux états unis ou en europe
de grand building et nous voulons nous
baser sur le même modèle mais ici c'est
différent
nous devons revenir à nos racines à nos
valeurs ancestrales le bois le roseau le
bambou pour vivre d'une manière durable
et respectueuse de l'environnement et
pour qu'il y ait moins deux morts l'une
des choses à faire pour prévenir le coût
colossal en termes de pertes humaines
tout particulièrement dans les pays les
moins développés et d'améliorer les
constructions je pense que nos
prévisions de séismes ne fonctionne pas
le mieux que nous puissions faire est de
se dire oui on s'attend à ce que des
tremblements de terre se produisent sur
les lieux situé à la jonction des
plaques aux endroits où nous constatons
d'importantes failles actives et ceci
doit nous conduire à s'assurer que les
villes et cités proches de ces failles
soit construite de telle manière que
lorsqu'un séisme se produit nous ne
savons pas la date mais lorsqu'il
survient on est préparé les bâtiments ne
s'effondrent pas sur les gens c'est le
moins que nous puissions faire pour les
populations tout particulièrement dans
les pays riches aux
seuls les immeubles très récents ont
subi des dommages mineurs ceux qui n'ont
pas respecté les normes de résistance
aux séismes ont été détruits
occasionnant des dommages de 3,3
milliards de dollars et causant la
majorité des six cent soixante treize
décès à déplorer
les mêmes problèmes de planification
dans les pays pauvres ont causé
d'énormes pertes de l'autre côté du
continent américain
les systèmes météorologiques de la
planète sont interconnectés d'une
manière que nous commençons tout juste à
comprendre ils ont écrit le scénario du
pire des cataclysmes de l'année 2016
tout a commencé avec un phénomène de
mousson en afrique de l'ouest qui ne
présageaient rien d'extraordinaire
alors la mousson africaine de cette
année était relativement active un peu
plus que la normale
la mousson africaine est annoncée par
l'arrivée de ce que l'on appelle les
zones tropicales qui sont à l'origine de
beaucoup de tempêtes tropicales
atlantique à ses débuts l'ouragan
matthew n'est que l'une de ces ondes
tropicales partie des côtes d'afrique de
l'ouest le 22 septembre avec des
conditions environnementales favorisant
un développement lent et une activité
orageuse croissante
l'ondé tropicale s'est déplacée vers
l'ouest à travers l'océan atlantique le
28 septembre
matthew se transforma en tempête
tropicale à une cinquantaine de
kilomètres au sud-est de sainte lucie
le 29 la tempête devint un ouragan à 310
km au nord-est de curaçao
le jour suivant il augmente à son
intensité en catégorie 5 à la plus basse
latitude jamais relevées pour un ouragan
de cette intensité dans le bassin
atlantique
l'ouragan matthew a commencé à se
déplacer vers le nord assez lentement ou
l'ouragan va-t-il toucher terre mystère
cuba et haïti ressentir le souffle
humides du monstre et lancèrent l'alerté
rouge sur toutes les régions côtières
le 4 octobre à 7h du matin l'ouragan
matthew classé en ouragan de catégorie 4
frappe haïti avec des vents de 230
km/heure
[Musique]
malgré l'anticipation les pertes
humaines et matérielles sur l'île furent
catastrophiques
[Musique]
plus d'un millier de personnes
trouvèrent la mort lors du passage de
l'ouragan mathiot et des centaines de
milliers de foyers furent détruits par
cette tempête
elle laissa plus d'un million de
personnes tributaires de l'aide
humanitaire et des dégâts estimés à
presque 2 milliards de dollars
[Musique]
après le saccage d'haïti cuba
le 4 octobre à 20h matthew fera pas de
plein fouet hao qu avec des vents de 220
km heure
[Musique]
longue de tempête cause à des dommages
considérables dans la province de
guantanamo la splendide vieille ville
espagnole de baracoa fut en particulier
terriblement abîmée
cependant grâce à l'efficacité de la
protection civile cubaine
aucune perte ne fut à déplorer
[Musique]
l'interaction avec la terre sur cuba
fille faiblir l'ouragan en catégorie 3
bien que matthew est finalement retrouvé
une intensité de catégorie 4 en quittant
cuba pour les bahamas le 5 octobre
matthew alors qualifié en catégorie 4
fera pas les côtes pour la troisième
fois cette fois sur l'île de grand
bahama
les préparatifs commencèrent alors
véritablement dans le sud des états unis
à la proche de matthew plusieurs régions
déclarèrent l'état d'urgence sur les
régions côtières et on leur donne à des
évacuations massives
[Musique]
au cours des trente six heures suivantes
la tempête longeait la côte sud est des
états unis s'atténuant progressivement
tout en restant au large avant de
s'abattre une quatrième et dernière fois
sur les côtes de caroline du sud
au matin du 8 octobre le cyclone avait
alors la puissance d'un ouragan de
catégorie les dégâts furent
principalement limités aux côtes de
floride et de géorgie aux états unis
l'ouragan causa la mort de 47 personnes
[Musique]
le 9 octobre mathieu repris la direction
du large et acheva sa transformation en
cyclone extra tropicales
[Musique]
l'odyssée d'un monstre qui prend tout
aux plus pauvres et pargneaux les plus
riches qu'ils frappent les plus pauvres
comme en haïti il ce fut un terrible
désastre en terme de pertes humaines
puis il est parti vers le nord si sa
trajectoire avait été d'une centaine de
kilomètres plus à l'ouest
mathieu aurait provoqué d'énormes dégâts
en floride mais quand enfin il atterrit
aux états unis il s'était affaibli ce ne
fut plus qu'une catastrophe en termes
d'inondations qu'en terme de vent donc
les états unis ont eu une chance inouïe
avec matthew alors qu'haïti manqua
cruellement de chance avec des dégâts
estimés à plus de 8 milliards de dollars
matthew fut l'ouragan atlantique le plus
coûteux de puissantes 10 en 2012
mais tous les pays ne sont pas exposés
de la même manière
[Musique]
il ya de grosses différences entre les
premières puissances mondiales et les
pays en voie de développement
je là où il est facile de souscrire des
polices d'assurance dans les pays les
plus riches
les gens ont tendance à construire des
immeubles solide de meilleur bâtiment
ils ont tendance à suivre les règles et
normes de construction et si vous
travaillez dans des pays en voie de
développement
on t'en vas plus de risques les choses
ne sont pas construites aussi solidement
il y a beaucoup de bâtiments dans les
zones inondables par exemple il existe
moins de protection pour les populations
et ce sont donc des défis très
différents à relever si vous êtes à
bisser des modèles de risque pour les
pays riches ou si vous réfléchissez aux
risques pour les pays pauvres du
tiers-monde mon poids de développement
dans lesquels les conséquences des
cataclysmes peuvent être cruciales pour
la vie des gens l'année 2016 a eu sa
part de catastrophes incendie
séisme
[Musique]
tempête
sécheresse
[Musique]
inondations
mais peut-on savoir quel pourcentage de
ces événements doit être attribuée au
réchauffement climatique
il existe aujourd'hui des techniques
permettant d'identifier la cause
on appelle ça des études d'attribution
donc ça se fait maintenant dans un
certain nombre d'universités quand vous
étudiez le climat mondial depuis 1950
dans une version de la terre où vous
avez l'augmentation des gaz à effet de
serre année après année et une autre
version de la terre où il n'y a pas eu
ces augmentations de gaz à effet de
serre et donc ensuite vous confronter
ces deux versions de la terre afin de
découvrir comment probablement une
situation extrême particulière ça peut
être d'extrême sécheresse ou d'extrême
précipitations comment cela se passe
probablement dans ces deux mondes et
cela vous indique à quel point les
changements climatiques et à quel point
le réchauffement global favorise
l'apparition de ces extrêmes
[Musique]
une certitude demeure les catastrophes
naturelles frappe plus les pauvres que
les riches
[Musique]
si nous pouvons au moins attribuer
quelques uns de ces cataclysmes créée
par notre planète vivante au fait
qu'elle se réchauffe il reste plus
urgent que jamais d'instaurer des
politiques climatiques pour protéger les
plus vulnérables de ce monde
[Musique]